can you guys believe that here we are  how many years later this is 2022 and  we're still hearing the truth come out  about how the hillary clinton campaign  spied on candidate donald j trump and  then even further they hacked into the  white house and spied on the president  there is no evidence of that and it is  not what the durham court filing says  the united states and then here were you  know it's still coming out it's shameful  i mean honestly what really should  happen is hillary clinton should be in  jail now of course  they believe in due process  the first thing would be well you would  charge hillary that would be the first  step and it's for a jury to decide  whether she should be in jail  it's not up to marjorie taylor green  they say that they are all about law and  order and they call for the imprisonment  not only of people who haven't been  found guilty of people who haven't even  been charged